oh mein gott ein halbes jahr aus
[Musik]
ein wunderschöner neuer tag erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft
fällt meine lieben freunde zuallererst
bevor irgendetwas hier stattfinden wird
werden wir der katze genauso wie der
crew ein grab errichten da ich der katze
kein eigenes grab machen möchte und auch
keinen richtigen platz für habe werde
ich einfach hier in das grab von der kuh
mit dem rindfleisch nur noch einen
fichtenholz bode einpacken weil das
meine einzige richtige erinnerung mit
der katze war ein stück kies weil sie
dadurch gestorben essen einen faden bei
katzen in minecraft fäden einfach
gruppen je wieder die erde drauf die
margarethen obendrauf und eine schweige
sekunde
[Musik]
tatsächlich kam erzählt man sich in
diesem projekt alles mache das schild
schreiben wir natürlich auch noch roman
rest in peace kuh und katze dann haben
wir das grab nämlich auch fertig und wir
haben für die heutige folge auch wieder
extrem viel zu tun ich weiß viele
erwarten die insel reparatur folge das
wird nicht der fall sein
tut mir leid und zwar werde ich mein
ganzes weizen mitnehmen und ihr seht
doch schon dass ich vieles von meinem
zuckerrohr zu papier umgewandelt habe
denn ich kann wohl hin so richtig gut
trade mir wo zahlreiche in die
kommentare geschrieben dass wenn ich das
lesepult vor einem dorfbewohner setzte
und er dementsprechend zusammen
bibliotheken babo wird dass ich dann
einfach mit ihm
[Musik]
warum wir hier ein roadtrip was hast du
dich irgendwo hier das dorf
[Musik]
keine ahnung was ja vorne ab geht
allerdings sieht es mir auch wieder nach
einem schiffswrack aus
von daher haben wir hier auch eine kiste
[Musik]
das kann ich keinem erzählen wie viel
glück ich in diesem projekt mit
diamanten und so weiter und so fort habe
das ist wirklich geisteskrank ich weiß
nicht ob hier unten auch noch was ist
hier ist ja irgendeine tür angedeutet
aber irgendwie befindet sich alles
andere bis malta ich würde sagen setzen
uns jetzt aber und unser brötchen mal
reinigen die fackel in die hand das
alles ein bisschen heller und fahren da
hinten zu dem dorf rebellen haben uns
tatsächlich leider ein bisschen
verfahren und waren plötzlich hier in
diesem wrack aber das ist ja nicht
weiter schlimm denn dadurch haben jetzt
in diamanten bekommen und in jemanden
brauchen wir auch wirklich denn ich habe
wieder ein ziel für die heutige folge
die zauberinsel hört sie jede chance
sein wird ich muss schlafen ich mache
mir im dorf jetzt einfach mal eine kiste
wo ich ein paar unnötige sachen von mir
reinpacken kann und dann begeben wir uns
nun auf die suche nach dem schatz der
dort hinten wohl auch irgendwo sein soll
also der selber in der nähe von der
kiste wo die schatzkarte gefunden wo
reger drei skelette im ernst
juli
oh mein gott
sie hasst
[Musik]
das kannst du wirklich keinem erzählen
wie oft ich in diesem projekt sterben
jetzt ist ja auch noch ein krieger der
affen nicht meine sachen die luft
sprengen er darf nicht sein die luft
sprengt wir begeben uns jetzt allerdings
erst mal auf die suche nach dem schatz
der soll nämlich hier vorne irgendwo
sein laut der karte irgendwo hier im
wasser bin ich dumm nein ich war nicht
dumm das hat zwar wirklich extrem weit
unter wasser da ich diese ganze sucherei
allerdings ersparen möchten wir jetzt
hier gerade einfach eine halbe stunde
vor und ihr seht mich wie ich den schatz
gefunden habe das ist nicht wahr ab dann
bei gott ist da viel drin alter schwede
war gucke ich will ein wo der schatz ist
und da schreib mir noch einer von euch
in die kommentare
titel von drei blöcken und am strand weg
mit euch das eisen schwert nehme ich mal
mit anstatt den verrotteten fleischer
das herz des meeres statistiker
ich sehe schon wieder nachbarn klingeln
eigentlich war mein plan bei dem dorf
hier vorne auch dass ich mir eine neue
katze mit nehme die sache ist allerdings
das herzige niemand scharf mit gekommen
ist du hast mich wirklich noch kann man
dieser folge angeguckt die sachen zum
trading lasse ich jetzt einfach mal
hinten in der kiste was ich allerdings
auf jeden fall hier beim dorf noch
mitnehmen muss sind die tolle kiste
bisschen was essen kann ich auch immer
noch mitnehmen diese bemoosten steinen
hier sind auf jeden fall wichtig es tut
mir leid dass ich jetzt die häuserpreise
wie komisch ist das eigentlich für die
dorfbewohner wenn irgend so ein random
spieler ankommt und plötzlich alles bei
denen kaputt macht die wichtigsten ja
das ist kunst wir sind jetzt allerdings
aus dem dorf meine lieben freunde denn
ich habe einen riesigen plan für die
heutige folge ich habe wieder einen
architektonischen überfall auf euch vor
ich bin ich bin bei einer stunde 17
ach ja wenn man eine halbe stunde nach
diesem beschissenen schatz gesucht ich
will wieder mit flipper unterwegs
wie geil ist das denn kann man so einen
delfin irgendwie zähnen oder so dass der
ja dann mein delfine sondern kann ich in
einer leine nehmen oder der zieht mich
oder so natürlich extrem geil führte
mich jetzt meinem schatz oder naja was
mir zahlreichen kommentare geschrieben
wurde war dass ich mit den kartoffeln
einfach rechtsklick aufs lagerfeuer
machen kann und dann bekomme ich
gebratene kartoffeln schließlich gleich
auf das lagerfeuer muss ich etwas machen
[Musik]
die braten schon ziemlich lange von
kannst du dich mal verpissen ich lege
die anderen drei kartoffeln auch noch
drauf in der zwischenzeit wo die beraten
werde ich mich allerdings an mein erstes
diamant crafting rezept setzen meine
lieben freunde denn ich werde mir mit
den ersten diamanten die ich gefunden
habe diesem projekt eine spitze jetzt
vielleicht warum denn ich möchte
obsidian abbauen meine lieben freunde
und dafür werde ich hier ein wassereimer
hinsetzen dass hier alles was sie die
anmachen kurz ausleuchten damit ihr im
video auf was zählt und jetzt erst mal
gucken ob ihr das ist nicht wahr dass
das kannst du nicht ausdenken
was habe ich für ein verdammtes glück
egal wie kann das denn sein degas das
nicht so viel glück haben sind die
ringsherum auch noch welche oder slava
okay ich gehe ganz schnell mal wieder
hier raus bevor jetzt die intruper kommt
bei mal im glück das kannst du doch
wirklich nicht ausdenken heute ein
diamant in einer schatzkarte gefunden
jetzt noch drei diamanten abgebaut auch
noch so völlig random der redstone
gewesen ich habe mein obsidian ich mache
mir ich mache jetzt erstmal alle
materialien für die zauberinsel und dann
müssen wir mal auf den punkt wir fast
zwei stunden
[Musik]
jetzt werden wir die zauberinsel bauen
und dafür muss ich erst mal nicht hier
ein bisschen weg bewegen von unserer
insel denn ich möchte dass das wirklich
eine eigene kleine insel wird weil
unsere insel wirklich mehr und mehr aus
allen nähten platzt so hier fordert
eigentlich ganz schön da mache ich jetzt
erstmal fünf stücken die richtung den
weg hier bei euch natürlich nachher weg
das sieht nach ein bisschen schöner aus
jetzt müssen wir hier ein bisschen um
die seite umgehen zack zack zack zack
ich mal kurz zuletzt
so ich habe das jetzt gerade mal zu ende
gebaut
also es ist nicht zu ändern das wird
noch ein bisschen schöner aussehen
allerdings wurde es währenddessen jetzt
auch nachts deswegen bin ich auch gerade
noch mal kurz schlafen gegangen
ich baue jetzt auf jeder seite von
diesem kreis den ich gemacht habe ein
wenig in die höhe und dann nachher noch
mal wieder rein in die mitte weil dann
von dort oben sondern laterne
herunterhängen wird habe ich mir gedacht
denn das hier ist genau der mittelpunkt
und dafür bin ich jetzt quasi alle
seiten so sieht dass sie jetzt erst mal
aus in die mitte kommt jetzt unser
zauber tisch ich weiß nicht genau wo die
mitte ist hab ich denke mal hier müsste
das so wie es die mütter hier kommt der
zauber tisch im juli
es ist schon cool aus um den zauber
zentrum platzieren wir jetzt einige
stufen das können wir beliebig irgendwie
antworten und ich mache jetzt
beispielsweise einfach mal so und hier
kommen dann quasi nach der die
bücherregale drauf ich habe jetzt zwar
erst eins allerdings kommen da auch
nachher noch die eichenholz falltüren
drauf und dann kommt hier quasi noch nie
bücherregal hin zwei übereinander jedoch
drei übereinander zack zack so dass wir
halt irgendwann das maximum voll haben
also 15 bücherregale um den zauberte
strom dann kann man richtig drauf machen
und verzaubern
ich möchte den eisen schwert rein und
sicherheit wieder
also ich bin und nicht so gut jetzt
können wir aber generell diesen kreis
sehen wir hier vorhin gemacht haben mal
so ein bisschen ja so ein bisschen
unnatürlicher machen finde ich
beispielsweise hier so ein paar blöcke
abbauen und allerdings zum beispiel hier
auch nochmal irgendwie ein paar blöcke
dran setzen dann habe ich extra ja auch
noch die modi habe ich nicht eingepackt
wir können jetzt hier vorne einfach mal
so ein paar blöcke am
und wegnehmen und da beispielsweise dann
so musste teile hinsetzen damit seinen
gegenständen hier um pac nicht hier
vorne noch einen bemoosten hin dann
sieht alles ein bisschen mehr
durcheinander aus was wir jetzt auch
machen müssen ist einmal kurz moment so
zac nach hier oben gehen denn wir
brauchen natürlich auch nicht dafür habe
ich ihnen hier eine menge ketten gemacht
und laternen und zwar mache ich jetzt
einfach zack zack zack zack dann hänge
ich alles darunter jetzt beispielsweise
die laterne hin ich zeig euch mal von
außen das geht ja jetzt nämlich schon so
aus im dunkeln sieht es natürlich immer
noch ein bisschen geiler aus aber wisst
ihr was ich baue das ding jetzt fertig
in der time netz und dann seht ihr wenn
es fertig ist
ich hab's ich bin fertig mit dem ding
ich weiß nicht ob ich zu viel
versprochen habe aber ich habe jetzt
hier vorne alles ein bisschen
durcheinander gemacht mit den stein
ziegeln und bemoosten steinstufen und
holz et cetera walter ist ein
bücherregal aber hier habe ich halt
laternen hingesetzt ketten wir haben
eine laterne die relativ lang runter
gegangen ist habe ich ab und zu so stein
ziegel ausgetauscht durch treppen hier
dann wieder blätter dran gemacht hier
auch treppen und jetzt sieht es
eigentlich ganz schön ausfindig wir
schauen uns das ganze jetzt noch mal bei
nacht an
dort sieht schon schön aus
der blöde damit sein gabel dies zurück
oh mein gott
bisher werden
[Applaus]
[Musik]
für den typen habe ich jetzt wirklich
keine nerven meine lieben freunde
allerdings haben wir das hier heute
geschafft es hat zwar sehr lange dauert
und die folge war wieder ein sehr
krasses hin und her aber ich finde
eigentlich ganz schön kommt mir ja mal
in die kommentare schreiben
das findet schreibt mir gern weiterhin
tipps etc und in die kommentare danke
für euer riesigen support und für ein
riesiges feedback zu diesem projekt wenn
es euch gefällt dann das geld einen
daumen hoch unter dem video hier da
abonniert main kanal falls nächste folge
nicht verpassen möchte denn die kommt
[Musik]